ladybugs beetles and hornets it's not a
bug's life it's bullet train brad pitt
is teaming up with the director of
deadpool 2 for a crazy crime caper based
on a japanese book here's everything you
need to know about the action-packed
flip
bullet train began production in the
middle of the covet 19 pandemic in
november 2020. the action film's release
date would also be heavily affected by
the pandemic being shifted several times
sony's original date for the brad pitt
flick was april 8th and its first
pushback landed it on july 15th when
black adam vacated its july 29th spot
sony moved bullet train to take over the
date this was so the film would have a
more significant gap between itself and
marvel studios thor love and thunder
which lands in theaters on july 8th
however it was revealed in may that
bullet train was moving to august 5th as
sony hopes to make their film the
summer's final blockbuster this movie
pits bullet train against universal's
easter sunday and a24s body's body's
bodies so if you could just like not
escalate the situation that i'm not
escalating you're holding the knife and
you're moving your hands while you talk
bullet train is based on the novel maria
beetle by japanese writer kotaro isaka
depending on how accurately the movie
adaptation follows the book's plot you
can expect multiple strange assassins
with radically different methods in the
same bullet train all tasked with
different jobs and largely unaware of
each other however as the story
progresses it turns out that their
missions might just be interconnected
after all and a deadly game begins the
novel is an exciting combination of high
octane action and a complex twisting
plot that's somewhat reminiscent of guy
ritchie's early films and according to
bullet train producer kelly mccormick
the movie version has all intentions to
deliver mccormick said i think the combo
in what this movie is which is kind of a
crazy crime caper is a really exciting
combo for fans as well as actors i can't
speak more highly of the picture and the
experience every day is an absolute riot
in july 2020 brad pitt hopped aboard
bullet train taking the lead as ladybug
known in the novel as one of the world's
unluckiest assassins ladybug is called
in for one last mission which calls for
him to steal a briefcase aboard a
high-speed train we won't go into the
details of ladybug's character from the
book to avoid spoilers but you can
expect ladybug's pass to come back to
haunt him bullet train is pit's second
film of 2022 following up the comedic
hit the lost city prior to 2022 pitt
hadn't been in a major motion picture
since 2019's at astra and once upon a
time in hollywood
joining brad pitt in bullet train is
sandra bullock bullock replaced lady
gaga who had a scheduling conflict with
house of gucci this marks the second
time pitt and bullock have shared the
screen with the lost city from earlier
this year making their first bullock
plays maria beedle the handler of pitts
ladybug and titular character for kotaro
isakka's novel maria appears quite often
in the second trailer confirming she and
ladybug will get some face-to-face time
but she will never step foot on the
actual train that second trailer also
reveals we'll see a lot of action
happening off the locomotive meaning we
might get more bullock in this film than
initially believed
when aaron taylor johnson joined bullet
train it was revealed he would be
playing one of the assassins on board
johnson's character the moustache-clad
tangerine worked side by side with
another contract killer who was also
named after a citrus fruit based on the
trailer tangerine seems like a
no-nonsense assassin playing the
opposite of brad pitt's easier going
ladybug those looking forward to seeing
bullet train should be especially
excited for taylor johnson's performance
sony bigwigs were so happy with the
actor's performance that they offered
him the role of craven in their upcoming
craven the hunter comic book flip taylor
johnson reportedly signed a
multi-picture deal with the studio to
boot taylor johnson seems to be equally
ecstatic about bullet train promising
it's an epic action flick that's equally
funny and thrilling he told the audience
in sin europe i watched the movie last
week and i was literally howling with
laughter to the point that i almost peed
on my seat a little but honestly this is
the summer movie you do not want to miss
i am not kidding making up the other
half of the bullet-trained citrus duo is
brian tyree henry who plays lemon lemon
will work side by side with tangerine
both of whom square off against ladybug
separately in the trailer tyree henry
has a hilarious one-on-one with pitt in
the first trailer for the film as the
two fight one another in the quiet car
of the train it also looks like they've
met before but we're not quite sure how
they're connected just yet remember
those two wackos from the bolivia jobs
the twins yeah and i'm so sure they're
twins when chatting with kelly clarkson
on her daytime talk show tyree henry
revealed he had a great time filming
bullet train and mentioned how much fun
he had with brad pitt the actor said
when the director would call cut during
their fight scene pitt would lay in his
arms and he'd get to hold him
one of the later additions to bullet
training was zazie beats whose casting
was announced in november 2020. the
atlanta star plays hornet another
assassin who appears to be impersonating
an employee of the train hornet hails
from the united states but her true
mission on the high-speed train remains
to be seen based on the trailer hornet
seems to favor a knife as her weapon of
choice and doesn't seem too fond of
ladybug this marks the second time beats
has worked with director david leach the
first of which came in 2018's deadpool 2
where she played domino when chatting
with collider back in march 2021 beats
gushed over pitt saying he was a delight
to work with on bullet train and hope
she can work with him again in the
future
joey king plays prince a british
assassin at the time of the casting
announcement it was revealed that king
was going to be one of the film's main
assassins possibly the only female we
know that ended up not being true with
the addition of zazi beats to the cast
so just how major king's role will
actually be remains to be seen the
actress was nervous to start filming for
the new movie however and admitted to
collider that her first day on set was
like the first day of school despite
being in the industry since 2006 the
bullet train set made her feel like it
was her first time filming king admitted
brad pitt and david leach were super
warm and welcoming and helped her to
shake her nerves she admitted i cannot
wait to see this movie because from the
stuff we filmed and from the stuff i saw
it is just so cool it is so ridiculously
cool
puerto rican music superstar bad bunny
was announced as a part of the bullet
train cast in december 2020. the release
of the film marks the rapper's first
ever major movie role he appeared in
2019's f9 in a blink and you'll miss it
cameo but his role in bullet train looks
to give him a substantial amount of
screen time bad bunny is playing wolf
another assassin aboard the train who
appears to have a not so fun history
with ladybug i will run you alive the
way you ruin mine
dude i don't even know you in an
interview with apple music bad bunny
noted that he messed up brad pitt's face
a little during their fight scene but
seda's co-star was super friendly and
respectful we have to assume the
musician nailed the road as he was
announced to take the lead in sony's el
muerto film at cinemacon this april
you probably know hiroyuki sonata from
well pretty much everything and now he's
adding bullet train to his resume the
avengers in-game and mortal kombat star
is playing a mystery character but based
on the trailer it looks like he could be
another assassin on board logan lerman
is also joining the bullet train cast
reuniting him with his fury co-star brad
pitt lehrman plays an assistant to
tangerine and lemon and spoiler alert it
looks like he won't make it out of the
train alive the first trailer reveals
lerman's character's death after
tangerine and lemon find him dead in a
seat knives out and man of steel star
michael shannon was also added to the
cast in 2020 and will be playing jay
wayne who looks almost unrecognizable in
the trailers with his hands covered in
tattoos and sporting long stringy hair
jay is a rather mysterious man who looks
like someone not to be messed with
filling out the bullet train cast are
andrew koji masi oka emelina adams pasha
d lynchnikov andrea munoz and karen
fukuhara in smaller roles
calling the shots on the bullet train
set was david leach the stunt man turned
director who once performed stunts for
brad pitt leach was pit stunt double on
fight club mr and mrs smith troy spy
game and ocean's 11. bullet train marks
the fourth major motion picture for
leech at this point he has atomic blonde
deadpool 2 and hobbes and shaw under his
belt all of which can be considered
successes any movie fan who has seen
more than one of those films should know
what to expect from bullet train a film
full of exciting action sequences and
high quality stunt work producing the
film as fellow action director antoine
fuqua who originally developed the film
leach also serves as producer as does
kelly mccormick zack okovich wrote the
screenplay for bullet train but don't
worry if you don't recognize the name
his only other credit is fierce street
part 2 1978.
two official trailers were released for
bullet train giving us a good glimpse of
the action that takes place on and off
the locomotive what's clear from both
trailers is that bullet train is going
to be a bright and colorful adventure
with interesting fight sequences taking
unique advantage of the space brad
pitt's ladybug is clearly at the center
of the film and looks to get involved
with every single assassin at some point
in the movie the second trailer depicts
more of ladybug's handler maria beedle
and appears to show the duo together
after the insane events that take place
on the high speed train pitch charm
takes center stage and he's supported by
a stellar cast who all shine in their
moments in the trailers based on both
peaks at bullet train we can guess the
movie won't take itself too seriously
and will be the perfect summer popcorn
blockbuster to close out the season i i
gotta get off this train check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]